straight up for 90% of you this is the
greatest year of your life right now
that's just the truth
you gotta be up in the office whoever
will be to corporate talk about
ownership and leverage KPI detectors
that out of every player in LA on top of
the USC football team
it's called Colin I'm team now to do
some articles
hey Colin how are you
super well real quick when you say brand
put your brand your product your service
your business you know what I mean when
you sit when you when you say document
there you're going to link that word
document to document and create okay
keep going what do you say if you're
thinking like a media company add or you
know end or a publisher got it and brand
and brand is everything if you're trying
to create a business of value now now on
the modern digital now in the modern
digital landscape instead of social you
make it one of the reasons I want to
write this article is you know I think
people see that alpha anger
competitiveness hunger you know how go
to [ __ ] Google dick and they they
misunderstand that it is under the
context and the guise of the business
game not over all life I don't even know
if I want to position at that like with
that title I think it's more about
dissecting dissecting being
misunderstood you know we need to make
it more of a macro conversation of
everybody being misunderstood like for
me this is less about a piece of content
that I want out there for me to point to
and more of a piece of content to
empower people to keep doing their thing
because a lot of them are not doing
their thing because of other people's
opinions for me I'm empathetic to being
misunderstood not combative
hey Tony Gary Vaynerchuk how are you
good
how's your summer going so far so I want
to talk to you about the creative pillar
and the pros and cons of where you want
to take it creatively and we'll have
that conversation right after this the
part that you could count on me is you
will be able to go to Long Island City
to our podcast studio and that is
literally where you can we will set it
up for you we will design the logo for
you we will get you on the iTunes and
Spotify and you know you know all the
Google platforms you will you know we'll
give you the kind of you know 101 of
like how to get people to listen to it
and where you send people will will will
do podcast in a box for you all you
really need to do is just come to the
studio and tell your guests to come to
the studio record and leave
what's the best and the worst part of
being a CEO which is everything's on you
the ups and the downs let's use anchor
from afar we don't know each other that
well but I follow an anchor very closely
from the beginning you know you came out
the gate and then there's that two to
three weeks when everybody was on your
nuts right like you were going to this
thing and like it was exciting and it
was the first time you did this and
you're like oh man what's that like
dealing with like Gary B's like talking
about all these people are talking about
it like VCS are coming at me real people
I looked up to impact care about me are
on the platform and then for everybody
who's listening tell them what's
happened over the last 12 to 15 months
you have that high and then the low
comes and you're and you're trying to
build the product and the articles
aren't being written about it and you're
actually have to operate that you
actually have to build something
successful and and there's a lot of
competition and there's the other
flavors of the week right so like the
loneliness of that is real I assume from
afar you know one week you're like oh my
god I'm the next you know Instagram and
then like a week later the market
doesn't care and that's what
entrepreneurs have to deal with like
everybody's excited when they start
their company what happens a month later
the answer to my question is I try my
damnedest I think about it every day I
obsess over my business every second I
obsess over am i doing the right thing
as a parent as a father as a husband as
a brother as a son as a human to society
and you let the friction of that
ambition play out every day and some
days you win and sometimes you lose but
you'd never give a [ __ ] what anybody
thinks about your wins or losses
and confidence and competence goes in
funny places like we're doing this
interview I would tell you listen I love
you and I love this platform so I'm
doing it but it's not the biggest
interview of my life
right and I got to tell you where your
your phone call comes and I know it's a
hidden number because I've been playing
with your platform so I knew as you and
it's so weird one went through my mind
which is I literally literally this went
through my mind I'm like I'm about to
give the best anchored interview of all
time yeah it's like one of the
most-watched beat YouTube videos of all
time but it was it was a maybe the
entrepreneurial class let's start with
this I fully fully 100 thousand percent
with no hedge do not believe that you
can teach entrepreneurship right so
that's awkward
how are you I'm never happier how's it
going
I just good it was your
reformism I grew up I was actually born
in Russia over a beautiful facility huh
you know how to do it here
but the reality is that's your reality
right like you know that that's the
reality but to your point there's
nothing against collecting business card
like it's only about relationships you
need to DAP it up with as many people as
possible That's Life is only about the
people I made tens of millions of
dollars because I became friendly I
thought Twitter was going to be
important and I made those relationships
with those founders and that's what
opened up everything everybody you
talked to ever ever that's made it that
really made it it's just relationships I
would meet every single person syphon
and learn they want to they want to see
you because they want to take a selfie
and show their fourteen-year-old son
they know you you want to see them
because you want to win life
[Music]
for me it's gratitude I'm super grateful
man like I was born in the [ __ ] place
got out of Russia when nobody was
getting out right like got lucky like
I'm grateful like if I wake up and
everybody my family is alive I'm so
[ __ ] fired up I don't want [ __ ] I
don't listen to [ __ ] I'm just like I'm
so grateful you know yogi like I look
like I just know you know I don't know
what else to say I'm just super dumb
part of this nonprofit pencils of
promise
I took some my people went to Ghana with
the Ghana land in the car and then drove
for hours this p-police is where people
walk an hour to get fresh water that
man's water bottle there they would
[ __ ] die for that [ __ ] like I just
think everybody's lost perspective and
I'm real empathetic this one's lost
perspective you're a football player USC
your perspective is broke it just is so
like I try to unwind like my
perspectives I'm a white man in America
and I'm rich as [ __ ] my perspective is
broke so I'm trying to rewind it back to
just be grateful I'm just grateful so
the way I stay on the edge and just like
gratitude it's just gratitude like one
life one at-bat one time I just don't
want to see that regret in my eyes that
I see in so many and that's why it's so
fun for me to come and talk to you now
because like straight up for 90% of you
this is the greatest year of your life
right now that's just the truth
used to be mad at me you can be sad at
me you could think I'm stupid telling
you straight to your [ __ ] faces for
80 to 90% of you this is it this is the
[ __ ] pinnacle so you better squeeze
the [ __ ] out of this thing because if
you're smart and you do then it won't be
it is good it's true you know like it's
not like I'm smart I'm just looking at
data
I'm just looking at history just talking
to people just being a student of life
it's true if they're doing it right
because
they're [ __ ] they're just not delivering
on the promise that I talk today Tamara
that's another thing why didn't they
what's your reason now that's the
difference right my difference was I
bought it because I'm going to buy the
Jets and I just wanted to learn for 30
years from now now a minute suck it up I
want to come on I'm being dead serious
because I want people understand I want
to tell you the truth I want in my
Wikipedia to say and then in the late in
2017 he answered the sports agency world
and he [ __ ] that up too yeah we gotta
go let's get a pic or unit JP yeah Stu
it George you're playing a straight-up
Robert you all do appreciate it man Rob
really awesome pleasure such a pleasure
man I'll see you man fishy ated 100% a
keeping it in blanking it would thank
you sim please good help that's fun
great all right we gotta go can't wait
points pause baby
[Music]
all right d rock let's see how this one
works
d-roc said you have a rant in you I go
No and then I said yeah see know what I
say said yeah I said yeah I said no in
my head that's why there's a funny way
to start this video just go to the USC
football team and I said something in
there that really caught my attention
all right where is this guy
hey how are you I'm good my name is mark
it mark
we just watched your interview with The
Breakfast Club thank you my motivation
or thank you my man come on I recognize
your physically she ate him a man have a
go on what's that it should be normal
walk home I can't I'm John Brown Charlie
Hill pleasure gamma I co-chair a
football team I played for a couple
years I [ __ ] on my shoulder behind
coach make sure be Wroclaw I talk to
students get the right become so you
still use uber yeah it's funny I can't
couldn't find my driver's side to use in
like the perfect spot you know what's
funny so what do you think I I just
Carol I mean I you think we should name
a team every man can that guy dude you
talked about wine and that dude is off
at you but it doesn't everything to my
best friend like my favorite baseball
player
did you lose money if there's anything
not if there's anything I can ever be to
help to anybody let me know take care of
it how are you good
[Music]